Apple has an advertising style that's as
iconic as it is copied the Internet,
is full of parodies and lookalikes from
competitors,
yet somehow the magic in apple's
commercials isn't spoiled even though we
know the formula,
it never ceases to blow our minds to see
the newest iphone commercial come out.
Why?
What makes apple special?
A big reason is thanks to the guidance
of Mike Markkula.
He was an early investor in apple and
was the vice president of marketing in
1977 when apple was first getting off
the ground.
Marcola wrote a three point marketing
philosophy that has been in the
forefront of the company ever since.
Apple's marketing focus.
He says,
should be empathy,
focus and impute with empathy.
Apple strive to connect with customers
feelings while other talk about detailed
specs and processor power.
Apple talks a lot about battery life,
the way it feels in your hands and the
way it will connect you with others.
Focus focused on accomplishing the main
goals and eliminate unimportant
opportunities.
While other companies make a million
different variations of their products.
Apple only makes a few.
When Steve Jobs came back to apple,
he cut down their number of product
lines from several dozen to four by
refocusing apple on a few products,
they were able to create a superior
experience.
Impute.
This is possibly the most important
principle of Margolis marketing
manifesto.
Mark Road.
People do judge a book by its cover.
You may have the best products,
but if you present them poorly,
it will be perceived.
If you present them in a creative
professional manner,
you will impute the desired qualities.
In other words,
the way an iphone ad is presented is the
way that the iphone will be perceived
and that seems obvious,
but this means that even the colors of
the ad,
whether the space is cluttered or clean,
the tone of voice of the narrator,
he animations control the way the iphone
is viewed.
Even though all of these have nothing to
do with actual performance and this can
either hurt or help a company,
which is why mark nature,
apple kept it as a guiding principle to
their business.
Fast forward,
40 years later,
apple is the master at using this to
their advantage.
If you watch an apple ad,
you can find everything you need to know
from the first few seconds,
even if the audio is muted.
Now that we know the three philosophies
apple uses to advertise,
let's talk about the types of
advertisements apple does in the
lifecycle of one of their products.
They pretty much fall into three
categories.
The introduction,
this is the first video and it's
basically a hype video pumped up music,
pretty screens everywhere.
Basically just showing off the phone.
Iphone seven makes the things you do
most even better.
It's the best iphone we've ever made.
The specs,
this is the second video they'll make if
they can get johnny ive to do this one.
That's the best point of this video is
to make people feel like their old
devices outdated and slow.
A ton of talk about redesign and a lot,
a lot of comparative words,
and they'll also use pretty sounding,
but ultimately meaningless.
Words like color gamut,
advanced sensors,
and unique.
To put it on a much larger scale,
we designed it's 78 percent more screen
area,
a greater level of precision.
We completely
re engineered the tuck subsystem,
increasing the sensitivity of the
sensors,
doubling the touch refresh rate the
most,
the highest greater risk,
specifically designed for much larger
display and see more precise multitouch
technology in entirely new for speaker
architecture in more an indifferent ways
flexibility,
we've developed a new technology,
more productive,
more creative and entirely new scale.
After the intro inspects,
it's all about narrative.
This is just classic content marketing
and what is that?
Basically it's when you tell a story
where your product just so happens to
facilitate or caused something to
happen,
but there's no explicit promotion.
Pay attention to this video because it's
the classic case of content marketing.
Oh,
you're watching your daughter at a Romeo
and Juliet.
Play in capturing that special moment.
Well,
catch it better with the new iphone.
This is a really good way to sell
anything.
This phase continues through the rest of
the product life cycle until they
announced the next device,
at which point we come to distancing.
This really isn't an ad,
but it's necessary for advertising.
This is where they wipe all the evidence
and the old advertisements from their
channel and their webpage.
This is so customers don't get
distracted when they want to buy a
refurbished and five,
when the iphone seven is out,
and this is also assuming never realized
they've been saying the same stuff for
years.
That's pretty much it.
Now you know how apple advertises.
Thanks for watching.